bassem bonjour alors qu'est ça aide le
président tunisien maintient sa feuille
de route avec des limogeages en série
le parti noorda accuse toujours le
président d'un coup d'état
constitutionnel il y réclame des
élections anticipées
bonjour devra effectivement depuis cette
soirée surprise le président de la
république a décidé de limoger son
premier ministre de geler les affaires
parlementaires et d'enlever au début tu
es tout leur immunité on a pu assister
en tunisie à tunis sur tout et sur
l'ensemble du territoire à des
mouvements de foule délié c'est des gens
heureux qui sont descendus dans la rue
avec eux étaient à drapeaux et des avec
l'action pour remercier le président ça
faisait déjà un certain moment que les
tunisiens de monter que le parlement
soit destitué et qu'on change de régime
on change de système politique surtout
dans un système politique est affectée
par une crise économique assez
importante et qui a été encore plus
s'enfoncer dans la précarité à cause de
cette crise du coronavirus deux
présidents price ait continué sa feuille
de route les limogeages continue
également n'a pu assister au premier
limogeage du premier ministre qui a fini
par démissionner indique le limogeage du
ministre de la défense
et puis depuis hier se sont inscrits au
journal officiel plus d'une vingtaine
voire 25 niveaux et limogeages notamment
celui du procureur général de l'état
celui le directeur de la justice
militaire
des conseillers auprès du premier
ministre ou encore des chargés de
mission la liste est longue liste de ces
hauts fonctionnaires limogé par le chef
de l'état et limogeages de vaud encore
continuer on a pu parler un petit peu
avec la population qui dans les premiers
jours étaient très heureux de ce qui se
passait mais là reste encore vingt cinq
et nous ont annoncé qu'il restait
suspendue aux décisions du président de
la république nous ont même dit pour
certains qu'on ne pouvait pas faire pire
et que le meilleur reste à venir
mais je vous propose d'écouter certaines
réactions qu'on a pu avoir hier en fin
de journée
c'est une décision sage
nous allons voir ce que vont donner les
jours qui suivent j'espère le meilleur
pour l'avenir car sincèrement la vie que
nous menons est très compliqué tout
son étouffé certains meurent de faim il
n'y a que des problèmes beaucoup de
problèmes sans parler du chômage
personne n'avance dans ce pays j'espère
que le meilleur reste à venir
nous sommes encore dans le flou mais
tant que le peuple et aux côtés du
président de la république ce qui nous
attend ne peut être que positif i'm not
aussi où déjà il est tout aussi les
forces de l'ordre et l'armée tunisienne
appartiennent au peuple tunisien et à la
tunisie sont à la base de notre sécurité
et notre fierté
j'espère vraiment qu'il va y avoir une
stratégie de travail
la situation va changer arrivé en tant
que tunisiens à l'étranger été surpris
par l'état dans lequel j'ai retrouvé mon
pays
sans parler du coc vide j'espère
vraiment que la situation va évoluer
avec une stratégie de la part du
président de la république c'est la
meilleure décision prise 11 ans même si
cette décision aurait dû être prise il
ya quatre ou cinq années déjà il n'y
avait pas d'autre solution intermédiaire
ce qui nous attend ne peut être que
meilleure vous pensez vraiment qu'on
peut vivre pire que ce que nous avons
déjà vécu c'est impossible
vous l'avez entendu une large partie de
la population qui soutient le président
sa feuille de route et surtout dans
cette décision
côté opposition c'est le parti islamiste
largement majoritaire au parlement le
parti et ennahdha qui est vent debout
contre la décision du président de la
république qui a même dit que c'était un
coup d'état constitutionnel
ennahda qui demande au président pour
lui de revenir sur sa décision après que
ses députés et le président de
l'assemblée nationale monsieur
ghannouchi est aussi du parti annahda
puisse regagner l assemblée nationale et
nador qui souhaite que les élections
législatives et présidentielle
anticipées soient organisées
très vite pour éviter que ce retard ne
serve de prétexte pour maintenir un
régime autoritaire je vous propose
d'écouter shimada avant des élections
législatives
il faut lever ces mesures et revenir à
la démocratie en tunisie que le
parlement reprenne ses activités et
mettre fin à son contrôle militaire
entendre le président de république est
bien décidé à continuer les tunisiens
attendent désespérément de nouvelles
décisions du président ces tunisiens qui
sont toujours enfoncer entre crise
économique crise politique et que les
sanitaires à bassam hcb en direct de
tunis merci pour toutes ces précisions